to me the book was eye-opening on a
number of level levels and
originally i didn't think cause i i
spent a lot of time
talking about this subject as well and
and researching it and i i like to think
i'm pretty
aware of what's going on so at first i
was skeptical that that
honestly the book could tell me anything
i didn't already know uh but it did
actually have quite quite a bit that i
didn't know and
the first is the most basic thing like
you just mentioned that this is uh
really especially among kids this is a
phenomenon that is
affecting girls the most i had always
thought of it as a primarily
male phenomenon so can you talk you
mentioned you want to explore why
girls are so susceptible if you could
summarize why that is i mean
why why are they so susceptible teenage
girls
in mental health distress anxiety
depression and other you know
anything from borderline personality
disorder to other um you know
psychological struggles have always been
susceptible to pure contagion they've
always been susceptible to the idea
that there's something really wrong with
them and that if they just lose enough
weight
or you know um
if they get control of these multiple
personalities or i mean there's a
you know they they come up with these
explanations sometimes they're
introduced from
by therapists in this case it's all over
the culture
and the and social media and the ideas
they look to the culture to figure out
what's wrong with them
and today the the answer that they're
landing on
is oh i know what the problem is i'm
supposed to be a boy and the moment a
young person says that a young woman
says that
she goes from a lonely teenager who may
struggle to find friends to someone who
is celebrated in her school
congratulated by her therapist and whose
doctor
can't wait to start her on a course of
hormones so this is kind of
uh we're taking these universal feelings
that all teenagers experience
especially girls and what we have now is
a
they're being presented with a with a
handy kind of framework
for understanding those feelings and
that's what brings them to
transgenderism basically
that's right i mean imagine you know a
young woman who you know prior era would
have
who would be anorexic and be convinced
that if she just lost enough weight
everything would be better it's very you
know
they latch on to because they are in
real pain this does not discount their
pain
we know that rates are very high of
anxiety depression self-harm
for this generation and they're in
they're in a lot of pain and they looked
you know psychological pain is very hard
to explain to someone
in a way that gets you noticed and in a
way that gets you
you know um interest and help
and what they want they want they want
the affection they want the celebration
and they want the attention
and one way to frame it so that they get
those things
um which which i think they do need they
do need attention they do need
compassion
but the way that they're framing it is
is not necessarily accurate in fact very
often i think it's inaccurate that what
they what they have
is not real typical gender dysphoria
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content